nous continuons d'entendre des histoires de dévastation,
de personnes perdant leurs
moyens de subsistance, de personnes mourant à cause des
inondations, vous savez, ce qui implique un
changement radical, vous savez, cela coûte un
effort très conscient pour essayer autant que
possible si vous ne pouvez pas inverser les
problèmes.  complètement à moins que nous ne devions essayer
autant de minimiser ou d'atténuer l'
impact croissant du changement climatique
[Musique]
étrangère [
Musique] une
partie du changement climatique, j'espère donc
que cette startup est un engagement sérieux et
pas seulement des promesses en mettant à disposition des fonds
pour vous aider à répondre  connaissez les
problèmes que les gens ont été touchés
à cause du climat.
La musique étrangère
utilise la nouvelle tendance de l'énergie propre et
ce sont aussi quelques-uns des problèmes
avec lesquels nous devons nous attaquer et que l'Afrique,
oui, nous voulons nous industrialiser, donc si nous sommes en train
d'être  encouragés à ne pas utiliser de combustibles fossiles,
nous avons alors besoin d'une technologie nécessaire que vous
connaissez lorsqu'il s'agit d'utiliser l'énergie renouvelable ou
King
étrangère.